showed his skill there bunted into
the net nice tangle nice goal he's
a game breaker fabulous hands what a goal by the
youngster turn over there bashing left for Nelson
scores the little teamwork there and the Islanders
a pretty good first period going good job
of just keeping the puck in fashing with a
real nice between the legs pass oh there's the 05
hole he's going to scrore across bastion's having
himself a pretty good first per and signed a
new contract and says uh hey guys you paid a
lot you're going to get a lot from me done that
it's just a couple chances the Hawks can close
out Donado for Taylor Hall oneon-one Hall scor
beautiful finish by Taylor Hall at the end of
a long PK and denado does a great job getting a
stick on it you know it's the lone defender back
there John Merill can't catch up with the speed
of Taylor Hall backand right around mark Andre
flurry there's a smile from Conor Bard Hughes
racing to join it's a two on one Phil DJI Cent
Hugh scores could have played in the labor cup
with those hands right on of midair Quin Hughes
ties the game in one Dy is gone to the races and
then realizes that Hugh is caught up as a saucer
pass that has no Landing here and doesn't need
it bunted into the net you decep he holds long
enough gets it over the sliding defenseman and the
Hand ey when he gets older he'll play pickle ball
hey in this period Hunton try to walk out of the
corner to the far hand and he SP nice Bow by Ben
Hutton there's guys you cheer for Ben Hutton's
one of them showed his skill there creates his
own face a basketball player creting his own shot
back to the spot wield and gunned it here's Cadre
behind the net coming towards the front backhander
scores if sheils was thinking wraparound he was
fooled on the spinning backhander conre makes
it four nothing and shielding the puck Pi the
wrap around fate and then to the back hand
and this is right upstairs and that's the far
Corner here's a steel nice dangle nice goal
clo jro putting on a show in the pre-season
and what a read by clo drew the veteran backand
to forehand reads it perfectly puts it underneath
the bar Bard will bring the puck out to Center
Hughes going to try get to the bench no he's
not he's going to try to defend but mcdavid's
behind him he's in he de to score he's a game
breaker and Conor McDavid just broke this one
55 seconds into overtime the Oilers take it two
to one and Conor McDavid shakes the shoulders and
then goes to his back hand what a pass though now
Sean steps aside near side Circle Linsky stays
with him all the way around it's Robertson in
front wide open net and he scores hard to leave
Jason Robertson all alone in front of the net
and he scores with 143 to go in the second period
molinsky stayed with Tyler seen behind the net who
threw a backhand pass out in front and Robertson
gets his second goal in the last three games two
on two the other way with Milano up the give and
go slotted strome back to Milano backand he scores
fabulous hands from Milano that is filthy man
what a back C shot under the bar overall marks
catching B even though the Miss pass Bano stays
with it gets it back he's running out of time
and space he goes forand backand and he puts it
under the bar that is a beautiful highlight re
goal current coyote 3 to one coyotes dancing coie
scores what a goal by the youngster look at this
I mentioned earlier that he's a dancer watch the
dance move right there and then gets himself in a
position when he spins the second time he's in a
perfect shooting position and he uses everything
to hoist that puck quickly to the top of the net
that is something you cannot teach that is pure
skill big smile Spence into the slot hands it
off kampe with a shot and he scores Adrien km
taking the drop pass from Australian native Jordan
Spence we've seen the pull and drop attempted by a
couple players in today's game and Kee will do it
as well once and then watch him square up he gets
himself in a shooting position where he's able
to lean on that stick the torque of the stick
modern day technology traffic going to the net
and the King's back within one CSU here's kre
again huo drag Mo Bri shot scores he just looks
everybody off missed play Sharon goic is going
to gather little bumper play and here's where
it's held and then fired past the blocker uero
a career year in Florida an off year last season
and they're hoping he can do more of that for
[Music]
Calgary [Music]
mer
the of the good how about that puck movement
Kevin with a man Advantage you're right really
efficient Puck moving look at the spinway pass
from bardi so he draws attention to himself and
he made that extra pass last time well this one
turned out perfectly as he puts it right to the
onetime of how Conor and he lets that rip top
Corner no mistake that was a beauty your team
over time oh scores oh they sneak it in short side
on Yan Bednar wow that found its way through from
s pulan yeah a tricky little severe angle but
right in here there's a lot of room with that
left pad coming off the goal post and he just
banked it in off bednar's left bad and an offen
and it's set up for wheeler SC wheeler will end
up with it here tries to get to Offman which he
does and then as the play is broken up that little
spin pass turns out to be a Beauty look at that
thing Jak precis with that pass decision just
he knew wheeler was over there and had to find
a way to get it to him owski in control advancing
again here's baners he's St back to the roof this
is a fantastic play by Matty baners in the middle
Kowski finds him quick to the backand perfect view
from my spot down here not not much room over the
shoulder thear is a big goal tender and he puts it
right in the corner pocket yeah a little forehand
backhand shovel faer moves it out top Clark wrist
shot blocked by Maro score Thomas on the loose
Puck battled at home of the back hand upstairs
on Hill for the Hat Trick and the game tying goal
wow bouncing Puck one bounceing back of the neet
to zador on now a dragon drive and score Zary with
a nice move that was a wicked tow drag you're not
going to see a tow drag as effective as this very
often whatsoever he represents shot watch him get
it here shot no pulls it right out of the lane
around B in then top Corner that is an attractive
release after it nearly outreached by Greenway got
twisted around here comes cage Thompson breaking
down the middle makes a little move and he scores
as soon as Thompson approached the goal protected
the puck on his backand he almost kicked his right
leg knowing the Stick of grave was coming in that
allowed him to power move from his back to his
forehand and just drag it around the left state
of trist gar and Patrick line will bring it up on
the wing for bstrm now it opens up right down the
middle of the ice scores line a follows the play
on the drive by David Urich right up the middle a
nice little pass across to the forehand of L who's
coming down the right side Levi's down he tries
coming across he's got everything in the bottom
covered Puck goes up Top Line gets his second of
the game what a fantastic play for p back across
the Bailey here's pson has a look walks right in
it AC the score what an unbelievable pass by
Drake BS absolute Beauty as he curl and drags
this through traffic Parker Kell's going to get
credit for the goal but this is all about Drake
Bon here's T Foley sliding it back extra pass
for brat moves it to Hughes he scores Tick Tac
Toe well talk about zipping it around tick T to is
Right Bill to Foley brat and neit all touches on
it before Hughes puts it away you know real heads
up play by the younger damage there with the One
Touch pass and then the Devils with a couple of
more over to Hughes from a pretty sharp angle
but he wires it Balo able to feed it down heckin
trying to pull free spins back behind it net pass
it to the short side score a nice look to Thomas
bordalo set up by William Eckland yeah this is why
Eckland is such a high pick shows you his ability
to elude and shake a check and then know that he's
going to have someone back door threads the needle
perfect pass bordalo shrugs his shoulders this is
really fancy Dave Seth Jones Bard wants it shoots
it it blocked away they're cheating over to Bard
Taylor Hall open Cory Perry is second of the
night wow beautiful Puck movement Cory Perry
was left alone a couple of times as soon as Seth
Jones and Taylor Hall made themselves a threat to
score it's just a great idea you've got a left
shot to a righty across the crease that's one
of the looks they're looking for and you know
Cory Perry can bury anything in and around that
blue paint beautiful goal great execution into the
Anaheim zone for piala on left wing hangs on wraps
it around and scor it's about speed on the attack
du does a good job of gaining the blue line and a
little chip pass sends F in he got Gibson to bite
on the short side post couldn't get across whiffs
on a one timer snatches it back off the right
cornerboards hits McDavid to the net shot SC put
it over the right JRE of ladar perfectly placed
power play goal David walks in and on the end line
elevates the puck up and over the shoulder and
that was just a seeing eye wrist shot upstairs Zar
had no chance he aims for that name plate Bob slow
at first left shot swings it off the right side
scores off the post and in it's just a beautiful
shot by Logan Coy John Gibson I guarantee you
thought he had that angle on the blocker side
completely covered but off the underside of the
crossbar and in impressive young player picked off
by Mar moves around G be marter slides that back
elander it's William dander come on the delay DS
everyone way too low so it sets up elander on the
nice pass but really the patience on the Finish
from Willie neander to drag it all the way past
oh see you later can't get it over the line and
a breakaway pass coju alone to the backand scores
what a move by giru but he catches Appleton a
little bit flat footed He bobbles the puck we
go quickly kachuck comes in to recover that loose
Puck and JW read the play the entire time he stays
low and slow on the wide side and it receives the
pucky with that backhand forehand he opens the net
right up for the game's first goal he'll gain the
attack line cross speed for Rael drops it to Pon
shoots and scores but look at that pass by Rael
as well off execution up ice in transition and
it gets back to Ricard Rael coming down that left
side and what creativity to go between his legs
to pull that off with a touch pass nonetheless
right on the tape of Pon it finds its way through
winds it up the left wing here's That twistle
Into the Blue Zone moving shoot the scores oh
what a brilliant an individual effort by McKenzie
Ed twistle and it happened on a delayed penalty
the Hawks were going to get a power play but Ed
twistle ignored the referee's arm in the air and
bolted to the front of the Blues net and wipes
it in behind Bennington that's a highlight real
[Music]
goal
[Music] [Applause] oh